あの今日のテーマは あの
それほど難しいテーマではございません
まあ 難しくしようとすればいくらでもできますけど
できるだけ 簡単なところをお話しいたします
まず仏教といって
我々は何をしているんでしょうか
ということは 今の社会状況から考えても知っておいた方がいいんです
世の中の人間というのは
もう何か主義を持ってるんですね
何か頭の中で 考え方を持っていて
その通りに行こう 生きていこうとする
そこまで勝手でいいんです
自分が何か考えて その通りに生きていると
それまで みんな自由だからね
構いません でも 自分が何か意見
何か考え方 何か主義を持っちゃうと
すぐ思い浮かぶのは 他の人々は間違ってるんだよ
私と違いますよ 私と違いますよと
人のことを考えること自体が 大きなお世話なんですね
自分一人でどんな主義を持っていても
それは一向に構いません
でも 他の人々は私と同じ意見ではありませんと
私と同じ生き方をしていないんだと
と思うところから まる大きなお世話で 人の自由を奪っているんです
自分に何か意見を持って生きている自由あるならば
すべての人々にも自分なりの主義やら生き方やら
持って生きていられる自由があるんですね
人間というのは基本的にそこら辺 間違っちゃうんです
例えば 宗教の世界で 人が桜の木を拝んでも
ブナの木を拝んでも もう勝手でいいんですよ それで
お犬様を拝んでも
お猫様を拝んでも もう勝手でいいんじゃないんですかね
でも お猫様を拝んでる人が
お犬様を拝んでる人が間違ってるんだと
犬で違いますよと というのはおかしいんです
そこで他人が自分と違うと間違っているんだと思ったところで
もう他人に対して差別観が生まれてきて
狂暴な人だったら できるだけの人を自分の考え方に
自分の生き方に入れ込めようとする
それでとことん 人間の自由というものはなくなっていくんですよ
人の自由を 奪っていく途中で
いろんな相手に対して迷惑をかけたり
悪いことをしたり 批判 非難したり
そういうことは とことん起きていくんですね
それで非難して 侮辱して
罵倒して 気が済まない時は手も足も出ますね 人に対して
そういうことで 何か主義を持つこと自体で
それで止まらないで もうちょっと余計なことを考えることから
世界の人間に
自分に生きていられる自由というものは奪われて
失われてなくなってしまう
結果としては もう大量の人殺し
もう残酷な行為
差別感 不公平なこと 戦争
そういうことが最終的な結果になるです
でも 誰一人も 何か主義を持って生きているのは
あくまでも幸福になるためなんですね
私はこの考え方で幸せだと
自分の何か苦しみがあって
何か問題があって 自分には何か不安があって
何か主義を持つ それは宗教的でなくてもいいんですよ
例えば 私は共産主義だよという方々は
自分の幸せは この共産主義という生き方から得られるものだと思うんで
それで構いません 私は資本主義だという人が
資本主義社会でなかったら 自分が幸せになれないんだと思ってるんですよ
それだけでは それではいいんですよ 別に
でも相手が資本主義じゃないんだと
この野郎と思うところはどうでしょうかと
相手が共産主義ではありませんと
なんとかして自分の主義に入れなくちゃいけない
と思うところから人間が間違っているんです
そこからすべての世界には 苦しみしか結果として残らないんです
苦しみしか残らない 願っていた幸せ
それが壊れるんです たった一つのことを 希望して願っているんですけど
そのものがなくなっちゃうんですよ
だから金儲かりたいと言って
その結果としてホームレスになるならば
その人の生き方は正しいと言えますか？
お金がない人は金儲かりたいと 何か行動して
その結果として金持ちになったとするならば
その人の道が正しいんでしょうに
もっと金儲かりたいと思って 持っていたものもなくなって
最終的には何一つもなくなっちゃって ホームレスになるならば
その道が間違っているんです
ですから 幸せを願って
幸福を願って 安心感を願って
心の安らぎを願って 何かを生き方をする
何かを主義を持って生活すると
その結果として
肝心な幸福 幸せも失ってしまうならば
気をつけた方がいいと
ですから 仏教の立場というのははっきりして
主義を持たないことなんですよ
何も主義を持たないと
自分の心というのはすごく自由を味わっちゃうんですよ
ものすごく自由を味わっちゃいます
そこでどんな人とも仲良く生活することもできます
どんな人を差別することもできなくなります
でも 主義を持たないことは私の主義だよと言っちゃうと
それは主義になっちゃうんですね
そこは気をつけないと
そういう人とも一回話がありましたから 私と
自分が何も主義を持てないんだと 言い張ってはくるんだけど
結局は 私の反論で うまくいかなかったんですね
そういうことで この 世の中っていうのは
政治的考え方から
戦争 不幸などが生まれているんです
経済的な考え方から
貧困だけ増えていくんですね
搾取と貧困
宗教的な思考から 人殺しと
それは 昨日起きた出来事ではありません
私は今日考えているのは
人間というのはもう 宗教思考というのを始めたその時から
他を差別することをやってきたのではないかと
だから宗教の歴史っていうのは 結局はっきり言うと
血の歴史なんですよ 涙の歴史なんです
虐待の歴史なんです
そんな無意味な 何かの信仰のおかげで
人類の文化始めてから どれほど人が苦しんだかと
どれほどの人が死んだかと
どれほどの人々が精神的に悩んだり
差別観で苦しんだりしたかというと
限りないんですよ
だから目覚めなさいと
物事をはっきり見なさいと
余計な主観で 余計な感情で
事実を...　何といいますか
ねじ曲げることをしないで はっきり見てみなさいと
だから目覚めなさいというのが仏教なんです
何か信じなさいではなくて
目覚めて世を見なさいと
自分を見なさいと　どんな世界か
自分が何者かと そうするとはっきりと見えるでしょうと
だからしっかり見る 見てみて理解していく道と
何かを信じて
もう何もかもその信仰に合わせて
その主義に合わせて生きる道と比べると
どちらが自然かというと
すべてのものは見て理解していく道が すごく自然で平和なんですね
わざと強引に見える事実さえねじ曲げて
自分の思想に変えていく道っていうのは
それ自体 束縛であって
人間には大変 苦しみということに 結果としてなってしまいますね
そういうわけで あの 仏教といって
別に何か主義を教えているわけじゃないんです
何か変な信仰を教えているわけじゃないんです
皆様方の自由を奪っているわけじゃないんです
今とっくに自由がない
今とっくに苦しんでいる
今 いろんな考え方で いろんな文化的な思考で
歴史的な思考で 感情で
好みで 足引っ張られている
束縛されている 手足 腰
首 もうどちらかで もう鎖で繋げているんです
それは一つ一つ破って自由にするために
ブッダが目覚めの道を教えたんですね
Awakening 悟り はアウェイクニングと英語で言うんですけどね
ウェイク(wake) 目覚めなさい 起きなさい
そういうことだから
人間 やっぱりどう見ても自由でなければいけないし
それは 体は自由になりませんけど
やっぱり我々は 心を自由にすることはできるんですね
体っていうのは 地球からもう借りたもんだから
これは地球の法則によって動いているんですね
それはどうにもならないんですね
そういうわけで すぐ即座に人々に
心を自由にする道をお釈迦様が教えているんです
今 皆様が実践した 生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますように
その一行だけでも この世の中の人間が理解するならば
これ どれほど智慧の教えかと
どんな角度で考えてみても
それが正しいと見えるはずなんですね
私に生きる権利あるならば
皆に生きる権利あるんだよと
私が生きていきたければ 生きていきたいと思うんでしょう
それはもう実感あるでしょう
であるならば もうたとえ小さな目に見えぬ生命にさえ
生きていきたいという気持ちは持っていると
これははっきりと誰でもわかっていることでしょうに
いろんな宗教で 動物なんかは殺して食べてもいいやと言ってますけど
食べるために作っているんだぞとかね
その時 私はもうすごい反論するんですよ
豚が食べるために生きている動物だと思うなら
なんで豚は逃げるんですかね 殺す時は
なんで鶏は逃げようとしてるんですかね
やっぱり一つ一つの生命が 自分で死にたくないという気持ちを持ってるんでしょ
はっきりしているんですね
そのはっきりしている事実を否定して
生きる権利 我のみにありと
言うと それはもう無知も ものすごい大変な
もうひどい状態 極端な状態なんですね
だから 世界にあるこの 一切のこの苦しみを作る すべての思考に対して
お釈迦様はたった一行で
サッベー サッター バワントゥ スキタッタ
(Sabbe Sattā Bhavantu Sukhitattā)
すべての生命が幸福でありますように
その一行でお釈迦様の答えがあるんです
それは感情的な表現ではありません
かっこいいことを言おうではないかと おっしゃったわけじゃないんです
その中にものすごい深い智慧があるんです
目覚めた智慧があるんです
生命のことを観察してみると
顕微鏡で小さな微生物でも観察してみると
一生懸命生きていようと頑張っているんですね
二 三秒で死んで もうわかれる
微生物なんかはね みるみるうちに分離
分解して分解というんですか
分裂して別々な生命になる　それも死なんですけど
前にいた細胞が死んで 新しい細胞が二つ現れる
体の材料は同じだから 同じ生命が
例えばアメーバは同じく生きているんだというアメーバは永久的に生きていることになりますよ
だって 分離して分離していくんで
そんなことはないんです
一旦 細胞分裂が起きたら 新しい生命なんです
だから そちらの生と死がはっきりあるんです
だから そういう世界を見ても
やっぱり一生懸命生きていようとは努力しているんですね
それで我々は何か主観を持って
何か主義を持って 自分だけの殻を作らないで
自分だけ閉じこもれる檻を作らないで
すべての生命は 全く同じ平らで同じだと
空気のように
空気っていうのはたった一つ 一個ではないでしょう
分子ですか？モレキュール(molecule)ですか
一個一個の空気が 別々にあるんでしょう
でも全部一つになっているでしょうね
海の水だったら 一滴一滴取ることはできますけど
でもどんな一滴でも同じ水なんです
同じ塩水なんです
生命を見ると それはその真理をはっきりと
そんな深い知識なくても わかるはずなんです
なぜそれがわからないかというと
我々の頭が ものすごく汚れているんです
憎しみで 怒りで エゴで
ものすごく汚れているんです
だから見えないだけ
我々に何を教えてくれるかと
学校などに行ったら 社会と学校が
心を汚すだけ
余計な態度を作ってくれる
あんたは偉大なる人間だとかね
何々人だからすごいやとかね
それだけでも間違っていて 恐ろしい考え方なんです
だからどんな民族も すごい自分の民族に対して態度を持ってるでしょう
結果はどうですかね 他人を殺そうとする
他民族を殺そうとする
それでやがて自分の民族さえも ものすごい苦しみを味わっちゃいますね
現代社会でいえば ユダヤ系の方々は 自分たちがすごい偉いと思っていて
他はもう関係ないやと　と思っていくことで
本当に頭も良くて 経済能力もあって
政治的な能力もあって
もう何の問題もなく 幸せに生きていられるはずなんですけど
あの思考のおかげで 怯えて生活しなくちゃいけない
苦しみながら生活しなくちゃいけない
なのに なんで我々のような
こんなに頭も良くて活動もできて
もうなかなかいろんなことできるのに
なんでそんなに 安定して平和で生きていられないかという
その変な へんてこりんな思考に基づいて生活しているからなんです
それで皆様方は すごいありがたがって 歴史なんか勉強しているでしょう
歴史っていうのは ほとんど嘘を書いてるもんですよ
私は何回もこちらでも言いましたからね
一般人の生き方は 全然書いてないんでしょう
農民の生き方とかね 百姓さんの生き方とか
例えば 今 日本の2001年の歴史 書こうと思って
皇室のことだけ書くと
日本人にどんな関係ありますかね
その人々は何時に起きるかとかね
何を食べているかとかね
誰が誰と結婚しているかとか
いつ即位儀礼を行ったか
いつ結婚したかとかね
そんなことを明確に書いてあっても
それが日本の2001年の日本の歴史ですかね
だから長い間の変化を 歴史で書いているんだから
それだけ書いてるんですよ
誰かさんが有名な人なんです
歴史っていうのは 勝利者だけの出来事だと
だから我々はそういうものを勉強して
自分の人生を設計する
生き方を決める 自分の 自分個人の主義を作る
それだけで 大変な危険人物になってしまうんですね
だから 世の中のどんな学問
どんな教え どんな 何にしても
人間は恐ろしい人物として 再構成するためにできているものなんです
ですから ブッダが目に見えてるんだから 苦しんでいること
目に見えてるんだから 人をお互いに殺し合いやってること
同じ家族 同じ兄弟にしたって
お互いに憎しみ合ったりしているんだから
これ何のせい？
いろんなことを教えてくれるせいでしょうに
兄弟でもお互いに憎しみ合うのは
例えば一人の子がもう学校の勉強は上手にできると
2番目の子は全く興味ないと
それで兄弟喧嘩する必要ないんです
でも 親やら社会やらね
お前が頭がいい お前が頭が悪い
そうすると その兄弟の間で差別感が生まれてくるんですよ
頭がいいのはいい子だと
頭が悪いのは悪い子だと言ったら
ああ 兄貴がいい子で 俺が悪い子だと
という気持ちが生まれちゃうでしょうに
そういうことになってくると
同じ兄弟でもお互いに憎しむことになってしまうんですね
だから何一つもこの世の中で　残念なことに
ないんですね　平等を語る
無制限に無差別を語る 教え 生き方っていうのは
だから人間が そういうまあ仏教で使っている言葉っていうのは
無制限というか 無量というかね
限りなく広げる 制限がとにかくない思考を
生命に対してもって生活しなくちゃいけないんですね
それを発見して教えたのはお釈迦様だから
仏教というんであって お釈迦様がこういうので
こんなものは誰にでも発見できますよと
明らかな事実だから
わざとあの湾曲させた教えではないんだから
これは誰にでもわかることでしょうと
ですから 仏教と仏教といっても
全く他の宗教と全く別な
もう他人が 仏教ではない異教徒だと
だから違うんだという考え方は成り立たないんです
本当の仏教徒であるならば
それはまあ仏教でお釈迦様は 名前はゴータマであって
全然 ゴータマ教と言ってないんですよ
それ見たってわかるでしょうに
これはゴータマの教えですよと
それはゴータマ教じゃなくて仏教なんですよ
目覚めの道なんですね
なぜお釈迦様は自分のことをブッダと言ったんでしょうかというと
個人ということを消しちゃったんです
ブッダというならば 誰でもブッダになれるんです
だから私は田中ですよという言葉と
私は人間ですよという言葉とを比べてみてください
私は田中です 田中一郎ですよと言ったら
たった一人だけの人間なんです
一人だけの生命なんです
人間ですと言った途端
この個人的な存在というのは消えちゃうでしょう
もう多数の生命の一個だけになるんです
だからお釈迦様は自分の教えは ゴータマ教ではなくて
仏教にしたんです 悟り開いてから 目覚めてからは
自分がゴータマ ゴータマと
時々他人からゴータマと呼ばれたことはありますけど
ブッダは自分のことはブッダという言葉を使うし
如来という言葉を使うんですね
お釈迦様が好んだのは如来
タターガタ(Tathāgata)という言葉なんですね
そのタターガタという言葉は もっと謙虚的なんですね
いわゆる ありのままのことはちょっとわかりましたと
ちょっとではなくて ありのままの状況をわかった人という意味で
タターガタと　いわゆる至るべき位置にもう至ったと
そういうことを言うと
皆様にも教えてあげることもできるし
みんなは安心してブッダの教えを聞くこともできるし
自分が成功してから 他人に教えたんですね
で そういうふうな思考こそ やっぱり
人間の幸福に至る
人間のお互いに憎しみ合うことは 即座に消える
生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにということを考えちゃうと
それ なんで幸せでありますように としたんでしょうかね
すべての生命は平等であるとか教えないで
そこら辺にもお釈迦様の智慧が見えてくるんです
すべての生命は平等であると言っても
だから何をと 聞いたらどうしますか
どうすることもできなくなっちゃいますね
ですから すべての生命は平等であるということは
あまり意味のない言葉
真理かもしれませんけど　我々にとって
だからお釈迦様 だから何をではなくて
幸福でありますようにと
我々には生き方を教えているんですね
それが人間の人生設計するときの基本なんですね
だから我々は何をしても
どんな生き方をしても
その基本的に そのすべての生命が幸福でありますようにということを
もう絶対的な条件で
絶対自分で破ることを犯すことのできない条件として 生きていなくちゃいけないんです
家を建てても同じ考え方で
畑を作っても同じ思考で
工場を作っても同じ思考で
すべての生命が幸福でありますように
だから世の中にはたくさんの教えはいりません
たったその一行で生きているならば
自然はどうやって守るか
エコロジーはどうするかどうかね
もう何て言いますか
全滅の危機に襲われている動物のことを どうやって何するのかとかね
そんな問題は一つも出てこないでしょうに
何とか国と何とか国の問題はどうしますかとかね
何一つ成り立ちませんよ
我々は一つ 国境とかなんとか国境線を作る時も
そちらにあるのは怒りですよ 憎しみですね
お釈迦様の教えでは 地球には全然 国境はいりません
人はどこに住んでいてもいいんじゃないんですか
そこでわざと同じ民族の間でも国境線を引いて
互いに憎しみ合う
だから私が聞きたい質問は
お互いに憎しみ合う お互いに殺し合う思考に基づいて生きているか
あるいはすぐ瞬時に 今から
心の平和 幸せ 安らぎを体験できる
この短い人生 何の苦しみもなく生きていられる道を選ぶかということなんです
悪いことに ブッダの教えにだけ みんなケチつけようとする
煙たがるというか なんかすごい気持ち悪がったりして
それは冗談じゃないと言いたいんだけど
まあ丁寧にしゃべらなくちゃいけないんだから
一応あまりそういう人々にあまり激しいことを言わないんだけど
本当によく言うんですね
自分たちが幸福かと聞きたいんですよ
何か偉い 何か考え方で持っているんでしょうかと
ただ 何一つわからない 頭ごちゃごちゃ状態で
なんか頭なんかもうなんかトラックなんかに潰された状態で
何一つもろくに考えられないんだから
もうケチでもつけてやろうと
私はもう本当はどんな反論でも相手にしたいんだけど
相手にならないんですね
そういうわけで 今日のテーマはそういうテーマなんです
すぐ即効性あるんだと
ブッダの教えは
目の前で効き目がないと信頼できません
ものすごい将来 世紀末とかね
なんとか終わってから
最後の審判が来てから
あんた方は幸せになるぞと
言うとちょっと どうかなと
言ってる本人にも自信がないではないかと
なんで延期するんですかね？なんでそれ
確かめることが全くできないところまで 延期するんですかね
地球のもう世紀末というか この最後の
世紀末というかどうか分かりませんけど
いろいろな宗教でいろいろな言葉を使ってますけどね
まあ破滅の時期と
それになってくると もう我々ではないでしょうに
その時は別な人間だから
問題は 私たちの将来はどうなるかということなんです
孫の将来どうなるかということでもないんです
ひ孫の将来はどうなるんでしょうかということじゃないんです
ですから やっぱりブッダの教えの特色は即効性
すぐドーンとその瞬間で効いてほしいと 結果は
だから今の世の中 ものすごい混乱状態で
いろんな人がいろんな考え方を言う　無茶苦茶でしょう
しっかりしたことって誰一人も言えない
でも 仏教を聞いてみてください　すぐ
きちんとした答え いつでも持っているんですね
で 実践してみれば その日から幸せになるんです
今というのは本当にもう 世の中というのは 主義のせいで
もう二度となかったぐらいの 二度とではなくて
一度も歴史でなかったぐらいの危機に襲われているんですよ
これが戦争になるんだと言いながら
戦争の火種を引き起こそうとしている
戦争になるんだぞということをわかっているんだったら
そうならないようなことをしてほしいんだけど
でも そんな能力はない
そんな智慧がないんですね
もしちょっと間違ったらどうなるかわからない状態なんですね
だから それぐらい危険はなぜ生まれるかと
昨日誰かがテレビで言ったんですけども
いくらアメリカが頑張っても アフガンを倒すことはできませんと
これもう長い戦争になったら
必ずもうアメリカ人がアフガン人の思う壺になってしまいますよと
まあ それは誰でもわかっている可能性あるし
それでそれはもう世界に広げて
お互いに憎しみ合うようになる恐れっていうのは もう明確にもあるし
なのにその火種を どんどん増やそうとしていますね
だから私たちは 全く関係ない立場からね
見てほしいんですよ なんでそんなに危機になったんでしょうかというと
それは過去の人々が
私の生き方こそ正しいと思っているからなんです
被害に遭ったアメリカでも 同じ思考でしょうし
被害を起こしたという人々も 同じ思考でしょうし
だからこの とにかく何かの思考に縛りつくと
もう恐ろしい結果になるんですよ
今 人に不幸 作ろうと思っているのは
イスラム教なんですけど
昔は別な宗教も よく頑張ったんですね 人殺しに
だから平和な教えだ 平和な教えだと言いながら
平和な教えだったら 一人の人も裁くことをできないはずなんですよ
だから教え自体 明確に目覚めて言っているわけじゃないんです
感情で言ってるんです
我々は平和ないい人間だと
どんなアホでもそう思ってますよ 私こそ正しいと
私が正しくないと思っている人がいますかね 世の中で
極悪を起こす犯罪者でも
だってしょうがないでしょうに そうやるしかない
自分をディフェンディング(defending) 弁解するでしょう
だから罪悪人でも 自分が正しいと思っているんです
だから自分が正しいという思考っていうのは
それ自体おかしいと 我々は仏教の立場から言いたいんですね
だから その思想的な間違い
いわゆる単純論理の間違いなんですよ
名前を言うのは大変 失礼だと思いますけど
その間違いっていうのはもう 各宗教にあるんですね
キリスト教にしても ユダヤ教にしても
イスラム教にしても ヒンドゥー教にしても
その単純論理の間違いっていうのはあるんですね
私たちが正しいんだと
だからお前こそ正しいと言うなよと
と私たちが言いたいんですよ
そんなものは理屈にならないんだと
だって「私が正しい」 次の人が「私も正しい」と
もう一人も「私も正しい」と言っちゃうと
でも生き方は客観的に見ると 3つの生き方でしょうに
だから それで否定しているでしょう
だからこれ単純論理で もう否定されています
で 結果としてもう大変恐ろしい
そこでこのイスラム教について イスラム教というのは
まあ機嫌を取るために言うんですよ
大変平和な宗教だと だからイスラム教は悪くないんだと
過激派が悪いんだと
と言っても 私は単純論理で考えるんで
過激派を作ったのは どんな思想ですかと
過激派が破壊的な行動に行ってもよろしいと
聖戦という言葉があったのは どんな経典ですかね
イスラムの人々は キリスト教の聖書を読んで戦ってもいいと
じゃあ戦おうと思っているんですかね
自分の宗教の本読んで そういうことしてるんではないか
だから口先で平和 平和と言っても
明確に生き方を見てほしいんですね
キリスト教も同じことなんですよ
イエス様のことは 平和の何とか 王子様とか何とか言いますけど
実際にその教えを研究する方々
その専門家たちの生き方は何なのかと見ると
イエス様は全然 悪いことをしていなかったんだけど
イエス様は別にね 誰にもそういう被害を起こすことはしなかったし
それは明確にあるようですけど
許しなさいということは言ってあったんだけど
その教え全体を見てみると
そうじゃないんですね
憎しみがあるんですよ
だから宗教家たちが 神学者たちが勉強して
イエス様 ちょっとあっち行ってくださいと
ちょっと休んでくださいと言っても
狂暴な態度をとる
だから 何かこの証拠のない教えを出すと 世の中の人間に
すぐそちらにあるのは 苦しみの世界なんですね
だからこれから我々は思う存分味わうでしょう
その苦しみの世界っていうのは
だから私は本当に悲しいんですよ
そんな長い時間 生きているわけでもないし
我々はほんの瞬間しかね
生きていられることはできないし
その間でなんで苦しむ必要あるんですかね
この短い時間で なんで泣いて生きているんですかね
泣いて泣いて生きて どう何の意味があるんですかね
私たちにはもう
だからお釈迦様はあなた方には十分悩みあるでしょうにと
余計なことに悩むな だって年取るでしょうに
若さが消えていくでしょうに
体が弱くなるでしょうに
どんどん病気になるでしょうに
それで ああ 楽しい病気になったとか言って手を挙げて踊れますかね
体が病気になるとものすごいきつくて
薬も効かないでしょうに
年取ることには 薬もないし
そこで自分が大事に愛している母親が死んでしまうわ
父親が死んでしまうわ
それで日々食べ物を得ることも大変苦しいし
ですから 我々には十分心配すること
悩むことあるにも関わらず
これ何なのかと
そんな暇が余裕があるんですか？だからお釈迦様はものすごい具体的に
あんた方には苦しみがあると
その戦争の苦しみ言ってないんです
どんな豊かな国で どんな美しい体で
どんな裕福な家庭ででも
人間に生まれたならば
もう十分もう苦しみがそこにもう セットされているんですよ
だからそれ心配しなさいよと
その教えから見ても 自分のことを心配する
自分が年取っていく 仕事をしなくちゃいけない
仕事も大変難しい 収入があってもほとんど足らないぐらい
子供たちにはもっとちょっと もっと楽にしてあげたいとかね
奥さんにはもうちょっと楽にしてあげたいとかね
もっときれいな服を着させてあげたいとかね
気持ちはあるんだけど
なかなか大変なんですね
だからそこら辺で自分の人生を考えてみなさいよ
そうすると 他人のことに
あいつは間違っているんだよとか
なんとかとかね いう暇がないはずなんですよ
そういう人々は 自分のこの短い人生で
どのように幸せに幸福に生きていられるかということを はっきり発見するはずなんです
他人に迷惑をかけたら
ものすごい大きな もうとんでもない迷惑でしょうに
自分呼んでいただいた迷惑でしょうに
これは日本語もことわざ
You asked for it という英語の言葉がありますけどもね
自分が お願いして呼んで 苦しみをいただくような感じで
だから我々は 自分のことを心配するならば
もう人に迷惑をかける暇がない
かけちゃうと そこで大きなもう余計な苦しみが返ってくるんだから
そうすると 各人が自分の心の豊かさのために
自分の安らぎのために頑張るでしょうに
ですから ブッダの教えに基づいて
かすかにでも人に迷惑をかけることはできません
人を裁くことはできません
仏教では裁くという概念さえもないんです
judgement (ジャッジメント) 裁くという
まあパーリ語で言葉はありますけど
そのジャッジメントを パーリ語で使ってvinicchayadhamma
という言葉なんですけど
それはもうちゃんと法律的に
法律的な裁判 何か問題が起きたら
その時どちらが正しいかという判断であって
自分の生命としての自分の判断というのはないんです そういう言葉は
皆さんはよく知っている自業自得という言葉がありますね
それは明らかに仏教の言葉で
自業自得だから判断いらんでしょうに
自分が蒔いたものは自分で刈り取る
別に誰かが判断 決める必要ないでしょうに
私がもみを蒔いたところで
誰かさんが来て 君 もみを蒔いたんだから
もう刈り取ってもいいやと
大きな嘘で そんな言葉
だから私が間違った思考で生きていると
当然のことに私が不幸になる
私は正しい清らかな思考で生きていると
当然のことに私が幸福になる
ですから 何の悪いこともしていない
ある国民が全く純粋な悪人にやられたということはありえないんです
悪 不幸というのは自分で呼ぶんです
来てちょうだいと だから
この世界の今あるこの 不安定な状態は
善と悪との戦いではありません
正と邪の戦いではありません
これは邪と邪の戦いで
悪と悪との戦いなんです
言葉で何言っても
だってどう考えたって
正が もう善が 悪と戦いませんよ
善人が悪人と戦いません
戦った時点で悪人だから
だから単純論理でも理解してほしいんですよ 人類が
偉そうなことをしゃべるんだけど
哲学書はいくらあるかというと
西洋世界では もう5階建ての建物があっても
もう入りきれないぐらいあるでしょうに
でも単純に論理さえ持ってないんですから
善人が武装して悪と戦うというと
何善人ですかね
だからお釈迦様がおっしゃっているのは
悪は悪で倒れるんだと
悪人が自分の行為で自己破壊になるんだと
だから放っておけと 余計なことをする必要ないんです
一人一人の人間にそんな余計なことをする権利はないんです
我々のある権利はたった一つ
他人の幸せのために行動する
それは可能です 他人はそれを迷惑だとも思わない
なぜならば 他も幸せになりたい
他も笑って生活したい
自分だけではなくて 他人も楽に生きていきたい
自分だけじゃないんですね
それは他人は希望しているんですよ
こういう私でも
みんな協力していただければありがたいと 思ってはいるんです
今もとっくに皆様方 一生懸命協力してくれる
それはすごく私はものすごいありがたいと感じているんです
なんてありがたいことですかと
この方々は自分の暇も全部潰して
どれほど苦労して協力してくれるかと
仏教活動のために
だから どんな人でも協力してくれという気持ちはあるんですよ
それで私が協力してくれというんだから
私に誰か協力することは
私にとって迷惑とかね
ということにはならないんですよ
ですから 我々にできる仕事というのはたった一つ
他人のために 他の幸せのために
平和のために行動すること
裁く権利は誰一人もない
戦うという概念さえ成り立たない
悪は悪で滅びる 善は善で幸福になる
そういうものは普遍的な真理なんです
故に これはもうちょっと プラスアルファで言わなくちゃいけないんですけど
故に仏教では一神は成り立たないんです
すべてのものを審判する
ヤクザの親分が成り立たないんです
だって善は善で幸福になるんだから
誰かいじる必要ないでしょうに
悪は悪で滅びるんだから
例えば皆様方は毎日 60本ぐらいタバコ吸うとしましょう
そうすると私のせいでがんになりますか？
あるいは政府のせいでがんになりますか？
あるいはタバコ工場のせいでがんになりますか
自分が吸ったせいでしょうに
だから自分の行為で自分が滅びるんですよ
あれ アメリカでこのね
タバコインダストリー(tobacco industries) というか タバコ産業から
ものすごいお金取ったんですね
タバコを吸った人々が癌になったなったんだよと
屁理屈ですよ なんで吸ったんですかね
もう なんて言いますか
間接的な場合は 訴えてもいいんです
間接的にタバコ吸ってしまう場合ありますね
その場合は その人々は 私たち被害者だと
あんたは空気汚染したんだと言って訴えてもいいんだけど
ですから ちょっと大げさな言い方なんですけど
麻薬を持ち運ぶのは禁止とかね そんな法律を作る必要ないんです
使うなよと　使ったならば勝手に死んでしまえと
こちらのせいじゃないと
でも本当は麻薬の原材料っていうのは 昔から世の中にあったもので
いろんな その成分っていうのは
体いろいろ病気治すためとかね 使っていたんですよ
例えば インドのアユルヴェーダの場合でも
ものすごい厳密にこれ調整して調合して
いろいろ薬などに使っていたんです それは麻薬機能は全くなかったんです
例えば アユルヴェーダは手術とかほとんどしないんだから
例えば 心臓発作なんか起こしたら どうしますかね
すぐ血液が流れるようにしてあげる薬などなどありましたけど 今はない
作れません だって悪用しているんだから 栽培も禁止
だから世の中のものを潰すということ自体
また一つ仏教から見れば非論理的なんですね
問題は自分にあるんだよと
いっぱいここに酒があっても
もう酒があったんだから飲んでしまったよと
だからアル中になったよ というのはとんでもない話であって
なんで飲んだんですかね
飲んだのは自分が誘惑されたと　あんたが弱い
それでお釈迦様は じゃあ強くなる方法を教えますよと
でお釈迦様は タバコ産業も潰せとかね
イスラム教の国では そうするんですよ
タバコとか酒とかね 持っていて見つかったら もうすぐ刑務所に入れちゃう
裁判もなし 自分の戒律を守るために
それより自分の心を強くすればどうですかね
むちゃくちゃ飲むんですよ 飲んではいけないイスラム教で
むちゃくちゃ飲む　日本にいる人々を見てください　そんなに
それなのに自分たちが正しいと
いくらテキストに書いてあっても
人格ができてないならば
どこかで教えがおかしいんですね
例えば女の人がもう頭上から もう足のところまで全部隠しておかなくちゃいけないんだと
なんでと　これは女の人を見たら 男を誘惑するんだと
なんであんたがそんなに女の体見ただけで誘惑されるんですかね
だから男の弱みはいいんです それは
その代わりに 女の人々を苦しめなくちゃいけない
どんな教えですかね
だから世界を潰そう 世界を潰そうと思っちゃうんですね
だから逆をブッダが教えるんです あなたが強くなりなさいと
だから欲の場合は このある人が
ある他の宗教の人が
世の中にある美しいものは欲であると すごい哲学的な言葉を言ったんですよ
ちょっと原文は思い出せませんけど
ヴィチットラーニ(vicitrāni) という言葉が出てきますけど
この世の中でこの美しいものというのは カーマ(kāma) 欲だと私は言いますよと
そこでお釈迦様の答え　世の中の美しさは カーマではありませんと
それに対して あなたのアプローチがカーマです 欲ですよと
サンカッパラーゴー プリサッサ カーモー
(saṅkapparāgo purisassa kāmo)
あなたの概念 あなたの思考がカーマですよと
花がカーマ欲ですよと言わない 仏教は
花に対する 自分のアプローチがカーマです
なんて美しい花ですかと
あ 持っていきたいと そこです 欲が生まれているんです
だから仏教というのは
綺麗な花 美しい女性なんか潰すな 潰してくださいということじゃないんです
お金を見ると欲が生まれてくる
美味しい食べ物を見ると 欲が生まれてくる
美しい人々を見ると 欲が生まれてくると
美しい音楽を聞くと 欲が生まれると
それ潰すんですかね
その代わりに 自分を心を育ててみる
聞きたくない音が耳に入っても
ものすごい美しい音が耳に入っても
何のことなく平安な心でいられるように
自己を育てて強くする
それ自体が平和なんですよ
だから仏教で 平和の教えと看板は持ってないんです
看板を持つのは恐ろしい人々なんです
この世の中で平和の看板を持った人は みんな戦争を起こしちゃったんです
で 仏教は じりじりと真理を語っていくんです
嘘だったら証拠を言ってみなさいと
間違ってるんだったら言ってみなさい　みんなに自由さえ与えているんです
これは神の言葉だから信じなさい ということはまるっきりない
反論してみなさい 納得いかないんだったら
どうぞもう調べてみてください
仏教は偉大なる自信を持っています
語っているのは当たり前の事実
だから仏教というのは
理性ある人であるならば
絶対神々にも人間にも
どんな智慧の人にも これが違いますよと言えません
頭狂ってると言えますけどね
それである 自分の国のことなんですけど
ある神父さんかな 新聞で記事を出して
仏教と比較して ブッダとイエス様というところで
ブッダの教えがレベルものすごい低いんだと
イエス様の教えがすごいレベル高いんだと
理由は イエス様は神ではありません
自分が何のことなく単純な人間であることは自分で認めているのではないかと
でもイエス様は 私は神であるとはっきり言ってるんだと だから上ですね
最低お釈迦様は預言者でもありませんと
それ見て私は笑っちゃったんだけど
もうガキではないんじゃないかと こいつはと
だから スリランカでは宗教的なそういうのは すごく自由なんですけど
まあそんなこと言っても
仏教の人々は腹が立って 殺してやるぞということはまるっきりない
大体 返事もしません 私でも返事できますけど
なんだ ただのガキだと思ってね
笑って終わっちゃったんだけど
やっぱり誰かがそれに返事 書いてあったんですよ
もう 2 3週間経ったところで
その返事読んでみても
いかに丁寧に書いてるかで
本当に素晴らしかったんですね
それほど立派な返事でもなかったんだけどね
でも一つ一つに答えであったんですし
もう反論できないぐらいに
で 最低預言者でもないと言ったところで
私はそれで自分が否定しているでしょう 自分の教えを
世の中で腐るほど預言者はいたでしょうに
一人もろくなことを言ってないんだから
言ってますかね
だからあれが仏教から見れば精神分裂病なんですよ
何か言葉が聞こえるとか
だからこの分裂病の人々の言うのをうわごとですか
そんなものに基づいて人生設計するんですかね
だからお釈迦様は はっきりと理解した人
証拠を持ってしゃべる人の教えに基づいて人生設計しなさいよと
今も現代時代までも あっちこっちからもう神の言葉を聞いている人が現れるわ
神を目で 目の前で見える人がいるわ
そんなにすごいんだったら すごいことを言ってほしいんですよ
言ってること全部 なんで外れるんですかね
だから客観的なこと全部 外れているということをはっきりしているんだから
イエス様というような
ユダヤ人の救済者として王様が現れると言ったのに
結局当時で現れたのに
ユダヤ人が全然相手にしなかった 殺してしまったんだから
認めなかったんだから あれほど予言があったのに
だから予言一つも合ってないんですよ
まあ頑張ってますけど
聖書はこの一つ一つ 予言をちゃんと 何といいますか
その通りに起きたんですよ
あんなものは すごい苦しい解釈であって
ノストラダムスの解釈と同じなんですね
ノストラダムスという なんか精神的な ちょっと変なことを言う詩人がいて
この世の中の人々は これこそ予言書だと思って
ものすごい苦労して解釈するんですね
私からは一つも合ってないんですけど
なんで予言者に明確に言えないんですかね
何年 何月何日
こういうことが起こるかとかね
例えば世界 地球スケールで大危機にありますよ ということがね
なんで言えなかったんですか？誰一人にも
私はそのニュースをテレビで見た瞬間で
いかに世の中儚いかと
瞬時に全部変わるんではないかと
この 1時間前 我々はものすごく いい機嫌で気分でいたのに
もうそのある瞬間から もう怯えなくちゃいけないと
だから一瞬先わからないという ブッダの教えが正しいんじゃないですか
ですから あの方が ブッダが預言者ではありませんとかね なんとかと言っても
ブッダが預言者とアホじゃないんだから ブッダは
精神的な病気じゃないんだから
自分で研究して 自分で調べて
真理を発見した もう偉大なる知恵
偉大なる天才ということの明確ですね
我々にできることじゃありませんから 頑張っても
弱くてね それほど頑張りもしないし
それだけの差ですけどね
そこで どんどんもっと
我々の教えの中身に入ってみたいんですけど
今日たった二つの言葉をテーマにしているんです
[Sandiṭṭhiko]
まあほとんど皆様方知っている言葉で
[Akāliko]
サンディッティコー アカーリコー という二つの言葉なんですね
このサンディッティコーという言葉
サンディッティコー
これがこの目の前に結果が得られるという意味なんですね
パーリ語だから 一つの訳では全部意味は通じません
だからサンディッティカっていうのは すぐ自分の目の前で
即効性あるということなのです　一つの意味
我々この実証というか すぐ証拠を 正しいか正しくないか すぐわかりますよと
それでさらに解釈して この修行しても
もう百年後で 一億年後で
あるいは何百億年後で結果が出るぞということは全くない
そういうことだったら 目の前の証拠はないんです
だから事実だから 科学的な事実も同じことですよ
すぐその瞬時に結果が出てこないと
良くないんでしょうね
その辺でこの仏教の強さというかね
なんで私でも すごく強く喋りますけど
これもともと強いんです
恐怖感とか怯えとか ひとかけらもない世界なんです
脅しっていうのは全くない　チャレンジはあります
チャレンジと脅しっていうのはまるっきり違いますから
ですから強くやってみなさいよと
すぐ結果が出ますよと
ですからやってみなさいと
エーヒパッシコー (ehipassiko) という言葉もあります
[ehi passiko]
こういうのは法の特色で
エーヒ(ehi) 来てちょうだい
パッシコー (passiko) やってみなさい
見てみなさい どうかと
それはチャレンジなんです
脅しではありません
これがやらなかったら あなたはこれこれぐらい不幸になりますよとかね
永遠の何とかになりますよ ということはありません
仏教では 永遠という言葉さえもないんだからね
すべては変化していくんだからね
変化しなかったら永遠な地獄も地獄ではありませんよ
だって火があっても燃えませんから
燃えても焼けませんから
だから 例えば 地獄が苦しみというならば
日々燃えて日々苦しめなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから そういうのはもう真理わからないから言うことであって
すべて無常ですから とにかく脅しはありません
その代わりにエイヒパッシコー
カムアンドシー (Come and see)
カムアンドトライ (Come and try)
やってみてくださいと
束縛はないんだから 嫌だったらいつ帰ってもいいんです
でも 仏教に入った人は一度も
理解した人は帰ったことはありません
誤解している人々はもう出て行きますけどね
自分の主観にチャレンジ 攻撃された瞬間で もう帰っちゃうんです
でない限りは 誰でも帰ったわけじゃない
なぜかというと 試してみれば本当に
その通りで 自分が幸せになるんだということが 見えてくるんです
サンディッティコーということは すぐ結果が出てくる
証拠がある 実証的なもので
その場で 証拠を一言 一言 証拠と一緒なんですね
アカーリコーという 2番目の言葉
アカーリコーというのは この真理が
ある時空関係にのみ通用する ということはありません という意味なんです
で 我々知っているすべてのものは 時空関係の中なんですよ
それはわからないで喋ってるんです
だから問題が来るんですよ
例えば寿司ございますね
寿司がおいしいですかと聞いたら そうですよと
でも寿司がおいしいですよという言葉が 論理的に間違ってるんです
寿司がおいしいのは ある時空関係の中なんです
寿司がおいしいですよと言って 私は今日 じゃあそうですか言って
コンビニで寿司買う 買って忘れちゃって
1週間経ったところで 食べようとしたら おいしいんですかね
だから それもやっぱり時空関係なんですよ
あんたってすごい綺麗な人ですねと 我々何のことなく言うでしょ
でも何のこと 言葉はそんなにややこしく喋れませんから それでいいんですが
我々でも それが事実を語っているわけじゃないんです
人が綺麗ということも その条件の中で綺麗なんです
条件変えちゃうと それは変わってしまうんです
ですから この人類の言葉の使い方は ほとんどそういう
この何て言いますか スタティック(static: 静的な、固定された)で
スタティック どう言えばいいんですかね
ダイナミック(dynamic: 動的な、変化する)ではありません
動的ではありませんね
すべてのものは動的なんです ダイナミックなんです
ですから 言葉も動的でなきゃいけませんが
言葉っていうのは一つのラベルだから
これが変わらないんですよ
だって ある入れ物に砂糖を入れて 砂糖ともうラベルをつけるでしょう
砂糖が誰か使って何も空になっても ラベルそのまんまなんです
誰かが砂糖の代わりに何か 他の胡椒を入れても
ラベルというのは砂糖ですということになっちゃうんですよ
この単語には その問題があるんですよ 言葉には
だからそれも仏教はすごい気にするんです
普通の人は全然気にしません
なぜ気にするかというと
その この動的な世界にスタティック
もう何か日本語ありますかね
静的な単語を言葉を使うと
それだけでむちゃくちゃになるんですね
トラブル起こるんですよ
ソ連がとんでもない悪い国だと思っていたでしょ　今味方でしょ
ですから この
例えば人います あの人は悪い人ですよと
言葉つけちゃうと その言葉を本に書くと
それは静的な言葉になっちゃいますね
でも あの人はということは 動的なもので
瞬時に瞬時に 瞬間瞬間 変わっていくんですね
ですから どんなものにも 本当は言葉は
当てはめることは かなりきつくて難しいんです
でも 人間がものすごい言葉に引っかかっているんです
初めからの言葉ありきですからね
それはちょっとおかしいんです
ですから この特にこの私たちは 互いに喧嘩したり 戦争を起こしたり
人に対して ものすごい間違っているような意見を持ったりするんですけど
これ どうにもならん状態になっているのは
我々は言葉に引っかかっているからなんです
例えば 親戚の家に訪ねていく
親戚はあまり ありがたがらなかったと
それでやっぱりこの親戚は良くないんだと 言葉で決める
接待はしなかったと 歓迎しなかったと
そこで言葉にした途端 もう何て言いますか
その何々親戚が もうこちらとは全く機嫌が悪くて 仲が悪くて
もう接待もしない 行儀も悪い親戚やってことを決めつけちゃうんですね
それから その親戚の家族に対して こちらでありったけの怒り 憎しみが
動的なこと 感情だから生まれていくんです
その動的な感情は この静的な言葉から生まれてくるんですよ
でも 自分が親戚の家に訪ねたって その親戚自体も動的なんですよ
その日で 何か出来事が起きたりしてね
何かの状況があって 訪ねてきた親戚を歓迎することはできなかった可能性はあります
だからそれは理解しない
そういうわけで この我々は いろんなものに言葉をつけちゃって
それからもう いろんな苦しみを味わっている
だから何一つも静的なもの
スタティックなものはないと
ありえないと という因果法則を語るんですよ
条件論理 因と縁の論理
それを否定できますかね 人間には
因縁論では間違っていると
だからそれがわかると 我々にはもっと楽に生きていられますよ
自分に対して人が怒っても あ 今の瞬間でしょうと
今の条件の中でしょうと
条件が変われば全部 変わってしまうと
だから気にするな 運ぶ必要ない
だからこの仏教のこの 煩悩の中で我々が使う一言あって
執着という言葉がございますね
執着ということは もっと違う言葉に入れかえると 運ぶ ずっと
運んでいるつもりです 我々何も運んでいないんです
あれは幻覚ですよ
例えば何々さんがもう悪人だというふうに 頭に言葉で入れて
その何々さん悪人ということを
その言葉と感情を持ち続ける
でも結局それ空っぽなんですよ
その人というのは ずっと変化していくんだから
だから運べない 人が私に対して怒ったとします
その瞬間だけのことなんです
それで私は その人に対する怒りというのは運ぶんです
永遠に 怒ったのはたった 5分かもしれませんけど
それに対して私の心に生まれた怒りを 私は死ぬまで持ち運ぶ
死ぬまで持ち運べないんだから
いつでも思い出して怒りを新しく作る
古い怒りから新しい怒りを作る
どんどんそうすると変わるんですよ
植物でも何でも種から植えて
それからまた種取って植えて植えていっちゃうと変化していくでしょうに
だから元の怒りとは まるっきり違う怒りになってくるんですよ 5 6年経つと
それがあまりも恐ろしい世界
あまりにもバカバカらしい世界
我々は何か意見 概念 感情を持っているつもりなんですけど
それ自体が空っぽで幻覚だと
目覚めてみなさいよと　見たらすぐ楽になります
すべて消えます あの妄想の世界
人を憎めなくなります
それだけじゃなくて 人に対してすごく愛着することもなくなってしまいます
なんてかわいい人ですかと
この人と一生でも もう一緒にいられるんだぞとかね
ただ頭狂うまで欲情が出てくるでしょう
そんな生まれません 今の瞬間だけだと
次の瞬間 また別だと そういうことで
お釈迦様が厳密に無常
ダイナミズムを教えているんです
だからダイナミズムと無常ということが すべて瞬間瞬間 変化するんだということは
それほど隠れているものではありません
神の秘密ではありません
神のみ知っている秘密では何もありません
世の中の事実なんです
だからこのこれを 3時ぐらいで始めたんですけど 講義はね
今 4時 twenty eight minutes
まあ 4時 28分になっています
で 1時間半経ってますね
周りを見てください 思い出してください 2時のこと
どれぐらい変わってるか 世界が　皆様のことを見てください
2時の時の皆様の体の心の状況と
1時間半経った今の体の心の状況とどうでしょうかと
いかに変化していっているかと
だから無常というのは 神のみ知っている秘密ではありません
どんなアホでも知っている事実なんです
ただ気がつかないだけ
それに気づいたら すぐ即効性見えてきます
人間が私はこれこれの宗教だ
私は何々人だ 何々国民だとかね
私は金持ちだ 貧乏だ 頭のいい人だとか
そういう もう あり得もしない
静的なスタティックな思考で苦しんで
他を憎んで 他を他に対してものすごい愛着執着を作ったりして
もの短かな人生っていうのは 地獄にして生きているんですよ
それでこの 無常ということを理解してみてください
すぐその瞬間から すべての頭の中にあったあの静的な概念すべて
なんかそう言っちゃうとおかしおかしく考えちゃいますから
いわゆるスタティックな概念というのは すべて消えてしまうんでしょう
だから 自分 自分という考え方さえも
ずっと自分と自分という言葉
この言葉の問題ですよ
言葉 砂糖の入れ物は砂糖の代わりに
胡椒を入れても ラベルはラベルだから 砂糖だから
だから自分というラベルをつけちゃって 赤ちゃんの時 我々は
死ぬまで自分というラベルで生きているんです
中身が違うんですよ 瞬間 瞬間
だから ラベル変えないから問題なんです
そこで無常をわかっている人が
この自分という その態度も 飛ぶんですよ
なんだ バカバカらしいではないか 瞬間でしょう
花火のようなもんですよ　瞬間だけの美しさなんです
次に全く違うもの 花火はポーンと爆発して
すごい綺麗な模様を作って
次の瞬間でもう空気汚染している
暗い煙のみ
あの暗い 暗い臭いでしょうし 火薬だから
その暗い煙と花火を比べてみてください いかに違うかと
すべてのものはそういうふうに変化しているんだ
だからお釈迦様おっしゃっている無常という真理を ちょっと目覚めて見た瞬間から
一切の苦しみというものがすぐ落ちてしまいます
そこで徹底した平和っていうのは成り立ちます
涅槃というのは我々 安らぎと解釈しますね
心の平安と訳せますよ
だから心の平安があれば
社会的な平安というのはもう何のことないでしょうに
平和のために戦うバカが成り立たないでしょうに
自分の心を平安にすれば
もうすべて平安なんです
で まあそういうことで
仏教ではアカーリコーと言うんです
少々皆さんは疲れているようですから
ちょっと 10分ぐらい休憩いたします
現代の方々はね
大体 インスタントが好きでしょうしね
で もう 1分でご飯を食べれば大変ありがたいということで
1分チンして食べるご飯もあるしね
こういうあのインスタント主義っていうのは
それ食べ物の場合があまりよくいいわけじゃないんだけど
心の場合はやっぱりインスタントの方がいいというのは仏教の立場なんですね
心っていうのはすっごい早く変わるもんなんですよ
体っていうのは変わるためには時間がかかります
薬飲んでも それはもう血液に入って 効いてくるまでは時間がかかります
で すぐ変わるってことはないんですね
体が時間取りますけど
心は時間取りません 我々のは怒るために
泣くために ほんの 1秒でも十分です
何かにそれなりのものに出会ったら
すぐ 泣いたり悲しがったり怒ったりします
例えば 怖くなるためにどれぐらいの時間かかりますかと
1秒もかかりませんよ そういう怖くなる現象に出会ったら
その瞬間でもう怖くなるんです
例えば 怖さ感じるために映画なんか見ている場合はもう
1時間ぐらいもっとかかるんですよ
ずっと見て見て
ゆっくりと心の感情を高ぶってもらって
それでクライマックスで怖くなるとかね
それがもう妄想の世界でそうなんですけど
実際はそうじゃない いくらわいわいと楽しくこのハイキングで行くとしますね
弁当持って みんなで歌いながら行くと
突然クマがよく行ったりしたら
その瞬間でもう全部終わりですよ あの楽しみが
1秒もかかりません 心変わるためには
それで楽しいも何もなくて クマの姿を見えた瞬間でもう怯えちゃって
もう怖くなって体が震えて
だから心変わるためには時間かかりません
なんで我々はそんなにも もう健康もおかしながら
それほど世界をインスタントにしているんでしょうかね
そんなにも物事を早く
動く必要はありますかね
新幹線のスピード足らないんだから のぞみを作って
それもまだ足らないと思って なんとかまた開発中でとかね
やっぱりその 物質を早くするのは ちょっと自然破壊でよくないんですよ
いい結果が出てこないんです
物質はゆっくり動いた方がいいんです 物質の速さで
だからこの交通機関が速くなればなるほど
さらに人間が大変になってくるんですよ
さらに忙しくなる さらに暇がなくなる
で 食べ物はインスタントになればなるほど
我々はどんどん体が悪くなってしまう
だから仏教では 仏教はそんな余計な話喋ってないんだけど
なんか仏教から考えると それは私の考え方だからね
あまりこの物質の世界を インスタントにしない方がいいんじゃないかなと
穏やかでした方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
でも心はそうじゃないんです
我々は心が早く行きたいんですよ
だからもう交通機関が速くなるように設計するんです
お腹が空いた瞬間で 心が食えと言うんですよ
でも米といって それから炊飯器に入れてご飯炊くともう 45分経ってるんだから
待ちきれないんですね 心が　体は待てますよ
お腹が空いた人が 45分待っていたんだから 死んじゃったんだって
絶対ありえないんです
体は待てます 心は待てません
だからインスタントの食べ物を作っておくんです
日本 チンするものは今 1分になっているでしょう
それで理解してほしいのは
心がインスタントでしょうと 瞬間でしょうと
ですから 仏教は
体のために教えている教えではありません
心を上達するために 心を完全にするために
心を強くして 人格を造って 解脱を体験するために教えている道なんですね
だから解脱ということは
心の変化過程で起こる一つの出来事なんですね
だから 体よりも心が必要なんですね
だから仏教はかかっている問題は心なんですね
ですから 当然 インスタント主義なんです
変わるのは 瞬時に変わるんだから
だから今から修行しておけば
死んでから天国に行くんだぞという話には
まあ 仏教的ではありません
なぜならば 今日 修行しておいても
それから死ぬまで 20年あるとすると
20年間で どんな人間でいるんでしょうかね
わかったもんじゃないでしょう
人殺す可能性もあるでしょうね
それでも 20年前 修行したんだからといって 天国に行ける
ちょっと理屈が合わないんですよ
ですから このインスタント主義っていうのは仏教なんですよ
ですから すぐ効き目があるんだよと 別に
効き目が早く欲しいというふうな人間の欲望のことを言っているわけじゃなくて
当たり前 すぐ効きますよと
それも仏教から見れば当たり前のこと
心がすごい早く変化するんです
ものすごい速い ですから
今 何かしたら すぐそこの結果が出てきます
とにかく我々の心がすごく弱くて
主観で ものすごく小さくなっちゃって
自我が強くなってしまって
それで ものすごい弱くて 怯えて生きてるんですよ
人間が自分という ものすごいきつい考え方で生きているんだから
自分という きつい考え方がついてきちゃうと
もう ただ成り立つのですよ
この生命の中で 自分というのはほんの一個の生命で
何の力も 何もなくなっちゃうんですね
だからわざと自分のここ 自分が
そうやって他から分離して 小さく 小さくなっているんです
この小さくなっていると
当然弱い　当然怯える
こう例えましょう　海の一滴の水と
海全体と比べてみると 一滴の水って何のこともないでしょう
その一滴の水は 海と戦えますか？
海を相手にすることできますか
だから一滴の水が ほんの小さな波一つ見ただけでも
怯えるんです　もし命あるならば
ものすごく怖く 大きく見えちゃうんです
それが我々心でやっているんです
自分がいるんだと思って
だから人間はあまりにも小さいんですよ
小さいんだから すごく怯える
ものすごく不安 外から何が舞い上がってくるか分からないんです
他人が自分に対して 何するか分からない
ものすごく怯えているんです
だから自信というのは ひとかけらも人間にないんです
自信ありそうに行動する人々は
ただちょっと精神的な異常だけ
成り立たないんです
それぐらい弱い あるともわからないほど弱い
例えば聖書 西洋思想では 心っていうのはないんだよと 平気で言ってるんだから
あの物質 唯物論やらね
まあ一応 今の医学の世界でも 心っていうものの存在は 全く気にしていないでしょう
あれは脳の機能とかね 言ったらいったで
だからあるとも わからないほど 小さくなっているんです
そんな小さい心で 私たちは生きているんですよ
歩いたり 座ったり 喋ったり 考えたり 仕事をしたりするのは
これものすごい もう小さな小さな この弱い心なんですね
ですから 人間の生き方では 何一つも うまくいくはずがないんです
何にチャレンジしても 成功するはずがないんです
ですから 当たり前で 生きる上で 得られるのは
失敗 絶望感 無気力と言うんでしょうかね
力がないという 自分が弱いと
そういうものすごく嫌な気持ち
毎日 毎週 我々は味わっているんです
ああ どうにもならない どうにもならないと
そういう風に きめ細かく微妙に
お釈迦様は人間の苦しみを探し出すんですよ
親が死んでいる苦しみとかね
洪水に もう作物は全部流されたとかね
そういう苦しみだけ苦しみってわけじゃないんです
それはある場合もあるし ない場合もある
お金がなくなったらどうしようかと
そんなものは お金がなくなってしまう場合もあるし
全然 もう死ぬまでにもなくならない
死んでからも残っている場合もありますからね
そんなものは そんな大胆に考える必要ないんです
でも大胆に考えてほしいのは 我々は
すごい この瞬間 瞬間 生きている上で
絶望感やら無気力感やら
いつでもお手上げ状態っていうのは 常に感じています
世界がもう限りなく巨大で
自分を襲っているような感じで 生きているんです
皆様が 服を着る時でも 自由じゃないでしょう
すごく弱くて惨めで 他人がどう思いますか？と思ってやっているでしょうに
だって 日本で真夏でも  ちゃんと背広にネクタイ締めて コートも羽織っていくんだから
本人にとってはあれ 楽でしょうかね
中なんか蒸し風呂というかね
サウナですよ  1日中 サウナの中にいて 仕事をする
それで楽しい そんなものは捨ててしまって
日本で随分夏にふさわしい服がありますね なんとかね
浴衣となんとかって　え？作務衣とかね
あんなものを着て 仕事をすればいいのに
なんでできないんですか？自信ないでしょ
全然自信がない 会社に作務衣着て行こうと
それぐらい弱いんですよ
それが弱みなんです
だから自分の体でしょうに　自分が買った服でしょうに
なのに 自分好き勝手に着られない
世間を気にしなくてはならないんです
世間様が命令する通りに するようになってるんです
世間様が決して 自分のために命令しないんです
何の意味もない命令ですよ
会社に行く人は みんな背広を着て ネクタイつけて行きなさいというのは
誰がどんなバカが 何のために意味があるんですかね そんなことは
だから世間ということが悟っているわけでもないし
存在もしないし みんな個人個人だから
でも 私が個人で思っているんだから
世間が存在することになっちゃうんです
それで 世間がかなり大きくて
自分がすごく強い だからそれで自分の自由がなくなっちゃって
言われる通りにしなくちゃいけない
会社が頭を剃りなさいと言ったら みんな剃るしか方法ないんです
あるいは髪の毛を伸ばして
何かポニーテールみたいな 何かゴムバンドでもつけて
男性たち みんなそう来てくださいと言っちゃうと そうするしかないんですね
だから女性の方々も ものすごい神経使うでしょう
服装と お化粧に対して
だからそういうことで
人間っていうのは 至るところで 小さいということを感じているんです
それも精神的に大変 苦しいんですよ　分かってないんだけど みんな
この気楽と穏やか 楽しいと感じないんです
いろんなアクセサリーを買って 体につけて 楽しく遊ぼうと思っても
あの中で すごい苦しみが回ってるんです
すごいストレス溜まってるんです
それで言いたいのはこういうこと
我々はそれぐらい 弱い心で生きているんです
ですから 幸福っていうのは 作ることはできません
それでお釈迦様が そんなに即効性ある教えを教えているんでしょうかと
やっぱりすぐ効き目が出てくる教えが教えているんです
それはちゃんと客観的に見てみなさいと
本当のところは 自分という主体が存在しないんだと
それは 一つの幻覚に過ぎないんだと
ここは 私がいるということは 一つの幻覚ですと
それが合成されて出てくる一つの現象ですと
耳から音を感じて 目から光を感じて
舌から味を感じて 体からいろんな感覚を感じて
それで私が という現象 一時的な現象が生まれるだけであって
理解してみなさい　そうすると
もともと 自分という主体がない ということはわかるんでしょう
そうすると誰に怯えるんです それからは
自分という主体がない場合 誰に怯える必要ないんです
それから怖くなる必要は何もなくなっちゃうんです　苦しみ消えちゃうんです
苦しいと言ったら 誰が苦しいんですかね　苦しいものはない
悟った人々の言葉をいつでも聞くと この誰ということがなくなっちゃうんですね
体が痛いと言うのであって 私が痛いとは言わない
これは組み立てているものだと　もうすぐ壊れていくんだよと
そういう世界で生きているんだから
何の苦しみもない 何の怯えもない
そこをすぐ 将来ではなくて すぐ体験してほしい
それで心が弱いんだからこそ
自我があるんだからこそ 我々には 欲が生まれてくる
世界が大きすぎだからね
大きくなりたいんだよ 自分も　欲が生まれてくる
それで大きくなりたいけど ならない時は 怒りが生まれてくる
そこで自分という主体 個体 実体は
もともとないにも関わらず あると勘違いしているんだから
それを無知と言うんですね
無知と言うんです あると勘違いしているんだから
これ合成している現象だと わかってないんですね
そういうことだから 心には激しい病気
それは皆様方 よくわかっている病気なんですよ
貪瞋痴っていう
痴はわかっていないかもしれませんけど
むさぼりと怒りではいろんな失敗するんだと
いろんなダメージを受けているんだと　苦しんでるんだと
自殺までするでしょ それで
欲のせいで自殺する場合もあるし 他殺する場合もあるし
怒りのせいで自殺 他殺する場合もあるでしょうし
欲のせいで怒りのせいで もう他殺だけではなくて
大量殺人まで 起こす場合あるでしょうし
欲と怒りで 国と国が戦争もするでしょうに
だから我々にとっては すぐわかる苦しみです
なぜその苦しみ生まれるかというと
心のこの病気なんです そこで
サンディッティコー ダンモー(sandiṭṭhiko dhammo)
というふうに よく言うんだけど
それは何なのかと ある日
サーリプッタ尊者にあるお坊さんが聞くんですよ
他のところでアカーリコー ダンモー(akāliko dhammo) と言うんですけど
それは何なのかと
もうダンマ(dhamma) というのはニッバーナ(nibbāna) なんですよ
サンディッティコー ニッバーナ アカーリコー
何なのかと そうするとサーリプッタ尊者の説明は
それはあの 今ある欲を
今 消える教えだと
今 ある怒りが 今 消えるんだと
今 ある無知が 今すぐ消える方法ですからと
サンディッティ　今 結果が出るというんだよと
説明するんです そういうふうに
それで ちょっと難しいかもしれませんけど こういうこと
我々には 欲も今 生まれるんですよ
10年前の欲で今 苦しむことはないんです
もうとっくに忘れちゃったんだから
今 欲が生まれる 今 怒りが生まれる
今 無知がある　今 無知があるんだから
今 私がいるんだと思っているんです
何か見ると その場で欲が生まれる
何か見るとその場で怒りが生まれる
そこで心はいつでも 現在で生きている　回転しているんです
隠れてないんです　心は今 汚れているんです
そこで心を直すことを 今 直すと
今の瞬間で じゃあ怒りが生まれないようにと直してしまう
欲が生まれないようにと 直してしまう
これを見ても 私は欲を作れない ということにする
これを聞いても 私は欲を作らないということをする
これを見ても私は怒りませんと
その瞬間で怒らないようにする
そこで平安を感じられると
そこで今 自分という自我意識があるんだから
今 苦しんでいるんだから これ今なくそうと
自我意識は合成されているものだと すぐわかりましょうと
そうすると今 心は平安を体験する
一回 平安体験したら それからは二度と騙されません 心が
幻覚だとわかったらそれで終わりですよ
例えば蜃気楼は 知らない人が見たら 本当の水だと勘違いします
そしてそれを探しに行く
いくら探しても探しても 蜃気楼だから水にはたどり着きません
探せば探すほど苦しむんです
さらに喉が渇くんです
そこで水ではないとわかったら また騙されますか？
こういう風なことで蜃気楼が起きるんであって
水がないところに起こるんであって
水があるところには蜃気楼は出てこないと
その機能もこういう機能だとわかったら
何のこともない もう二度と騙されませんと
また 仏教ではこの呪いの 呪い師ですか
マジシャンに例えています 世の中
心が幻覚を作る 大変な鋭いマジシャンだと
だから 我々には もうないものを あるように錯覚を起こすんだと
実際にこの頭の中 例えば音が耳に触れるんだけど
この音は音 ただ音だけですよ
その音は言葉にするのは 私の頭の中なんです
その言葉に解釈するの 私の頭の中なんです
入った音は 音楽にするか 雑音にするかっていうのは
この頭の勝手なんです
それ自体 全部幻覚世界で プロセシング(processing)世界で
組み立てる世界なんですね
実際に目には 何も美しいものは映りません
ただ光の粒が ぶつかっていくだけ
それは適当に頭の中で情報を交わして
いろんな視覚というものを作るんで いろんな場面を
だから実際 私が見るものと皆様が見るものは違います
私が何を見ているかということは 私に何が見えているか
私の頭の中で 何が合成されているかということは 皆様には知り得ない
皆様は何を見ているかということは 私には知り得ない
青いって何色か誰も知りませんよ
言葉でみんな知ってるんだという錯覚が起こるだけ
この色何？あ これは青い色　あ そう　で終わっちゃいます
でも青いって私が何感じるか
他が何感じるかっていうことは 全くもう成り立たない世界 わからない世界
そういうふうに 心っていうのは不思議に この 何といいますか
マジックを起こしてるんです
それでコミュニケーションということがあるんですね
我々は互いに通じているんだと　嘘ですよ あんなもん成り立ちません
言ったことよく分かった　分かってくれたと
全然分かってないんです
こちらの言葉が耳に触れると その人の頭の中で
もうその人の勝手に妄想概念 幻覚が起こるんですよ
それは何か私がわかりません
私が勝手にその人の顔とか 反応とかいろいろ 分かったと思うだけ
それで そういうからくりを明確に見たら
今 見ないとわからないんですよ
音が耳に触れる瞬間で それを見なくちゃいけないんです
音が耳に触れた時は よく聴いて 喜んじゃって
それから 後で修行に行くんだと っていうのは成り立たないんです
我々は1秒しか生きていません　煩悩はその1秒で現れる
その生きている 1秒で悟らなくちゃいけないんです
ですから 仏教は ものすごいインスタント主義なんです
それでサーリプッタ尊者が そうやって貪瞋痴を
今 ある 貪瞋痴をなくす方法を教えているんだよと
故に今 結果がすぐ即効的に 即効的な教えだよと
だから一回 その幻覚のからくりを破った人にとっては
もう二度と騙すことはできない
ですから 本当の平安 安らぎというんです
それが最高の安らぎ そちらに言葉がないんですよ
この平安の状態 何なのかで言葉は成り立ちませんから
言葉の世界も破っているんだから
悟った心っていうのは 人は見えませんから
音楽は聞こえませんから
もうそれはすべて幻覚だから　言葉も幻覚だから
一切 幻覚破ったんだから
もうそれで終わり すべて言葉も人間の思考も
だからすべて一切 乗り越えたところだと言うんです
でも 一切乗り越えたところ 言った途端 言葉で考えちゃうと
この世のものではないと感じちゃいますよ
でも この世のものなんです　今の1秒のことなんです
それは厳密に 仏教でいう即効性のある悟りっていうか
それで皆様の実践の世界から考えてみてください
我々は ヴィパッサナーという 見るという 目覚めて見るというのを教えています
皆様方 怒りが生まれた瞬間で
これ怒りだと 自分と別にして見てください
自分と同一化しないで
これ怒りという ある感情だ
見えた瞬間で消えるでしょうに
欲が現れたら 今 欲という感情ですと
ああ 好きです ああ 好きですというと もう主観的で もう幻覚の中なんですよ
ではなくて 好き 欲という感情ですと
ちょっと見てみください　見えた瞬間で消えるんです
時間かかりません 見えたと同時に消える
それ以上 速いことは 世の中ではありません
これが一番 速いことです
普通の世界で 怒りを抑えるために どれぐらい頑張るんでしょうかね
誰かと憎しんでいるとする
その二人の憎しみをなくそうと思っちゃうと
どれぐらい説教しなくちゃいけないでしょうかね
何年も頑張るんでしょうね
だから即効性ないんです
だから誰かと誰かと別れた
腹が立って お互いにいろいろ喧嘩したりする場合は 仲直り
例えばユダヤ人とパレスチナ人の間で 仲直りしてあげようと
思ったら できると思いますかね
この我々ありがたがっている現代知識で
現代思考で 現代技術で
心理学でもかなり発展していると思っているでしょうに
ポリティクス(政治)やら インターナショナルポリティクス(国際政治)やらいろんな
相談する ディスカッション(議論)する 会議を行う
もう技 技術 いろいろ本いくらでもあるでしょうに
そういうものは全部勉強して
じゃあパレスチナ人とユダヤ人を仲直りしてあげると
結局無理でしょう なぜ無理かというと
そういう方法は 即効性ないんです
だからこれで見てください 単純に
自我がないんだと
そちらにパレスチナ人もユダヤ人も存在しないよ それは単なる妄想だと
ですから パレスチナ人が石一つ投げちゃったらね
怒るでしょうね 怒りが生まれたと
怒りが生まれた 自分の具体的な怒りを見る
あいつはパレスチナ人だ 石を投げたら
撃たなくちゃいけないんだとか そんな妄想やめて
怒りだと思ったら その瞬間で消えるでしょう
ですから 即効性というのは そういうもので
世俗的な生き方では もう絶対成り立たないことで
これは智慧でもって 自分を見たらすぐ消える
そうやってこの 見ていくと
物事は生まれて消えている　生まれて消えて 生まれて消える
えらい勝手じゃないかと
怒らない人であっても もう場所が変わったら怒ったりする
怒っている人でも場所が変わったら怒らないとかね
だから自我 人格とか自分とか性格とか何だと　成り立たないでしょうと
皆様方は絶対他人のものを奪わないでしょ？と思ってるでしょう
人格だって　そんなことないんです
もしどこかに行って 何もないところで
自分に何もないところで
もう空腹感で
でも周りに誰かが何か持っていると奪わないと思いますか？
その条件でやっちゃいますよ
日本人が世界一 行儀はいいと思ってるでしょ？
外国に行ったらどうですかね
だから そういうのは成り立たないんですよ
日本の中で そうなんですけどね
だから人格っていうのはないんです
その時その時 すぐ変わる
だからそうやってなんか変だと　これ自分がないんじゃないかと
我々は例えば 女の子の仲間に入ったら また違う人格で
男だけの仲間に入ったら また違う人格で
電車に乗ったらまた違う人格で
そういうことを観察していくと
何だこれ 自分というのは どこにもないんじゃないかということが見えてくるんですよ
そういう智慧が現れてくると
むさぼりと怒り 闘っていると どんどん無知も消えちゃって
智慧がパッとひらめいてくる　それから問題は全部解決します
ですから 効き目があるということは その瞬間でもわかります
ということで この方法と結果
道と目的　私たちにはかなり時間の隔たりがあります
大学に入ったら 4年間の勉強と最後に卒業だと
そうやって人間の世界では
この道と結果っていうのはかなり時間 隔たりがあるものなんです
仏教というのは それは一つなんですね
一緒になっているんです
隔たりがない
そこなんですね　この道元さんのこの曹洞宗のね
まあ思考で もう彼は頭ばっかり働かせていた人で
修行と悟りというのは一緒 というふうなことを言ってますけど
それをまた妄想で解釈して それも間違っているんですね 後で
ですから 座ればそれだけで悟ってるんだよとか何とか言って
修行の方法もなくなっちゃってね 大変なことになってますけど
まあ座っただけで悟って仏になるわけじゃ ブッダになるわけではありませんし
道元はそんなこと言ってもないんですけど
解釈する人々はもう 自分でもう欲に溺れてるんだから
いいことに それをいい方向へ解釈しているんですよ
でも 全くとんでもないことを言ってるわけでもないんですよ
厳密に この 今日ご飯食べたら
来月満腹になりますよという話はバカバカらしい
ご飯食べると同時に 満腹になっていくんですよ
それを言ってるんです
ですから ヴィパッサナーという観察方法をすればするほど
その分 その分 幸福感を味わっているんです
無我感を味わっているんです
みんな何やってるか自分でもさっぱりわからない ただ そのそれ無我感なんですよ
私が修行してるんだ 私がここまで進んでいるんだという実感があると
それはヴィパッサナー瞑想じゃないんです
だからただやっているだけ ひたすら
そうすると そこでも もうとっくに 自分がない世界で
でも ものは動いている
すべて動的だからね
だから自分という主観がなくても
もう勝手に物事は動いているんだということをね
すぐわかるんでしょう
もうちょっと頑張ればね すぐ鼻の先にあるものですよ
この完全たる解脱というもの
で そこら辺は厳密に説明すると
仏教のこのすぐ 結果が出るという話ね
それぐらいだと思います
あとは 一般的な俗的な例というのは いくらでも出せますけど
そこら辺言うべきかないか　まあ時間の関係もあります
で あの 昨日の勉強会でも言ったエピソードなんですけど
このインドで大変 有名な
ものすごいインドのもう歴史の初めからでもいた ある家なんですけど
バーラッドワジャというバーラッドワジャ家族ですね
家族で言うんで 家柄ですね
このバーラッドワジャ家の人々っていうのは
バラモン人の中でも もう最高級なレベルで
で ヴェーダ聖典を作った仙人たちの 一人の家柄です
で あるバーラッドワジャ家の家で
奥さんがなんとなくお釈迦様に出会って話を聞いて
こんな宗教 全部捨てちゃって
1番目の段階で悟ってるんです
だからやっぱり 幸福修行者っていうのはブッダの世界ということでね
もう確認していて でも他宗教を批判することも何もないんですよ
自分 結婚した相手がバーラドヴァージャ系のバラモン人で
その人の仕事はちゃんとやっている
ものすごい立派な奥様なんですね
だからそのバラモン人も やっぱり自分の奥さんのことをすごく大事に
いい人と一緒になったって満足して
仏教の人だからね 何も問題を起こしませんし
すごい明るく元気でいるし
でもバラモン人というのは口癖で
何かいつでも呪文みたいなものを言うんですよ
宗教の世界で そういう世界だからね
彼女もそういうふうに育てられたし
だからなんとなく癖で 何か言わなきゃ気が済まないんですね
何か祈り文句か 何か言わないと
オーム(oṃ)とかね フリーム(hrīṁ)とかいろいろありますよ
オン ナマ シヴァーヤ(Om Namaḥ Śivāya) とかね
南無妙法蓮華経とかね
南無阿弥陀仏とかいろいろありますよ
口ずさむ言葉っていうのは　宗教の世界で
そういう癖ついちゃうと 何か言わなきゃ気が済まないんですよ
でも 彼女はそういう世界はもう一切 捨ててるんですね
そうすると もう何か起きちゃったら 何言えばいいかなとわからなくなっちゃったんですね
例えば 浄土真宗系の方々だったら
もう死んだ人を見たら 南無阿弥陀仏という習慣がありますよ
日蓮系だったら南無妙法蓮華経とか
何か言わなきゃ ちょっと気が済まんですよ
怪我しちゃったら 南無妙法蓮華経 すぐ言っちゃうんですね
それ彼女にとってはもう 何言えばいいかと 何もなくなっちゃって
彼女は自分の先生に礼をして
ナモー タッサ バガヴァトー アラハトー サンマーサンブッダッサと言うんですね
それは具体的で もうお釈迦様は本当に悟った人だと 悟ったお釈迦様に礼をしますと
で 神の代わりにお釈迦様にしてしまったんです
だからもう なんかちょっと何かにぶつけたら
すぐナモタッサ(お釈迦様に帰依します)って言う
それであのバラモン人が困って
自分たちがヒンドゥー教の最高級の 10人ぐらいの家族かな
それぐらいの一つですよ　だからそれぐらいの立場の家の奥さんが
全く自分の宗教と関係ない呪文を唱えちゃうと
やっぱり家として 困っちゃうんですよ
困るんだけど いい奥さんで何も言えないんですね
ある日 すごい行事がありまして たくさんバラモン人が来て
この彼女 接待していたんですよ
そこで 何かこぼれちゃって こけちゃって
何のこともなく ナモタッサということを言ってたんですね
だから出来事は大きい出来事だから
ちょっと大きい声で言ってしまったんです
そこで他のブラマン人たちが なんて汚らわしいことを言うんでしょうかと
全く 邪教の言葉を言っているのではないか
こんな聖なる行事の時はとか
汚しちゃったんだと　で 怒ったんですね
怒っても奥さんはもう ヒンドゥー教って 儀式 儀礼は男性がやっているんだから
何のことなく自分が台所の方に行ったんだけど
あのバーラドヴァージャさんをさんざんやられちゃったんで バラモン人たちに
いくらなんでも 自分奥さんのことはものすごく叱ったりすると もう
これはもう腹が立ってきますね
そこまで言う必要はないんだ あんた方にはと と怒ってしまって
でも行事が終わった時は 奥さんに当たったと思いますね
お前のせいで 私はもうなんてひどい目に遭います
プライドは粉々に傷ついたのではないかとかね
ものすごい大恥かいちゃったんだよと　何よと それは
このブッダを信仰することをやめてくれませんかと 言えば
違うでしょう と言われちゃって
彼女はめげません 悟っているんだから
あんたね そんなに怒ったりするよりは
私は信仰でブッダってどんな人か 一度会って話してみなさいよと
会ってみて気に入らなかったらいいやと
じゃあ そう 会ってみますと
こちらもすごい知識人で もう勉強
もうもうもう最高なレベルまで勉強しているすごい人だからね
すごく混乱状態で 落ち着きがなくて
お釈迦様に対して すごい失礼な態度をとって いろいろ話してるんですね
話していて とにかくお釈迦様は全然混乱もしなかったし
怒りもしなかったし 落ち着いて答えていたんですね
それで じゃあ宗教的な質問をしてやるぞと
あんた何か一つ言えますかと
この 何を捨てれば人は楽になるか
何を捨てれば 人は心穏やかになって 平安を感じるかと
宗教家として 絶対やってはいけない
絶対なくしてほしいものって何だと思ってますかと
すごい難しい質問をしたんですよ
一つだけ言ってくださいと
この一つが消しちゃえば
それで全て終わりという 何かあったら言いなさい
言ったら お釈迦様がこの人すごく怒っているんだからね
そうですね この怒りなくしちゃえばと
私は心落ち着くと思いますよと
怒りが消えると 心はすごい平安になると思いますよと
宗教として言えば この怒りというたった一つのことを
絶対 破滅にするべきだと 言えるんだよ
と言った途端 あのバラモン人がびっくりしてしまっちゃうんです
すごい言葉ではないかと　本人が怒って混乱して
あ 怒りだと　これで見えちゃったんですね
見えた瞬間で消えちゃったんですよ
消えて あの一言で すっごく心の安らぎを感じたんです
なんて　そこ そういうことなんです
今まで怒りに怒って 混乱に混乱で苦しんでいた人が ある日 聞いた途端
安らぎを感じて　ああ 並みの人じゃないんだと
やっぱりさすが 自分の奥さんが
ブッダに一方通行で 信頼してるのわかります ということ
でも奥さんに負けてはたまりませんからね
だから出家しちゃったんです
出家して悟ったんです 完全に
お釈迦様と喧嘩しようと言って
そこで彼の弟が それにはものすごく怒って
お釈迦様に計画 立てて 侮辱してやるぞと言って お釈迦様を家に接待したんです
食事作ってあげますと
で 食事作ってあげる計画は全くない
でお釈迦様が来たら ありったけの言葉でお釈迦様を
罵倒したり 侮辱したり けなしたり 批判したりしたんです　ずっと
お釈迦様は全部 何のことなく聞いていたんです
聞いていて 彼の計画というのは 人にね
お接待しますから来てくださいと 頼んで侮辱して帰しちゃうと
その人 帰ってからも苦しいんですよ
なんであの人の家に私は行ったんですかと
こんなくだらないご飯食べるために　なんて恥ずかしいかと
そこまで計算してあったんです
それでお釈迦様 全部終わったらあなたにちょっと聞きますけど
あなたがこの あなたの親戚に豪華な
料理をして接待しようとして 用意したとしましょう
そうすると その親戚たちが 何か用事があって家に来ない
家に来ない場合は あなたは作った料理にどうしますか？と
その場合 私は作った料理 私と私の奥さんと子供たちで食べますと
ああ そうですか なるほど
それであなたは私を招待して
今はこの侮辱とけなすという
まあそういう非難するという接待をしましたと
でも残念ながら 私はいただけません
ですから 君と君の奥さんと子供たちで 十分受け取ってくださいと
お釈迦様は 何のことなくお返ししちゃったんです 全部
一言も人を叱ることしないで
優しい言葉で 全部返してあげたんです
その瞬間で ああ やっぱりお釈迦様には負けたと
この人は絶対 怒らない人だと
言って その人も出家するんです　そういうことで
バーラドヴァージャ家のほとんどの偉いバラモンたちが 仏教徒になって出家しちゃったんです
だからお釈迦様は その場でその人の問題を解決する
その場で安らぎを与えてあげる
お釈迦様に反論して倒してやるぞと来る人が ほとんど悟って終わっちゃうんです
その座った場で
だからその現実的に今の問題を語るんだからなんです
今 泣いてるんだったら その原因をなくしてあげる
それの普遍性も教えてあげる
例えば ある人がね 自分の子供が死んだったということで頭狂っちゃって
あっちこっち どこへ行っても解決方法ない
お釈迦様のところに来たら お釈迦様が彼女に
やっぱりみんな死ぬんだよと 教えてあげたんですね
きちんと経験させて それでなんで死ぬことみんな死ぬんだから
なんで悲しいのだろうね　当たり前のことだから
だって雨が降って我々びっくりしないでしょう　当たり前のことでしょう
今はちょっと暗くなってるんだから びっくりする？
当たり前だから びっくりするバカがいないでしょう そんなことに
だから 人が死ぬってことは当たり前なんですよ
なんでそれだけびっくりして 悲しくなるんでしょうかね
それで あ それは心に愛着あるんだからと
そのものについては ですから
ものに愛着があると そこにあるのは悲しみだよと
だから君が どんなものにも愛着しないようにした方が
すごく幸せ 楽でしょうと　ああ わかりましたと
道がわかったと その場で悟るでしょう
頭は狂っていたんだけど
だからそういうふうな教えなんで だから質的には 全く他の教えとは違うんですよ
ある人が お釈迦様とものすごい喧嘩して
還俗して 他宗教に行ってしまったんです
修行はうまくいかなかったんですね　ちょっと欲出しちゃったんです
欲出しちゃうと 仏教の世界じゃないんだからね
超能力欲しかったんですね
それは仏教では禁止 欲だからね
得る世界じゃなくて捨てる世界だから　得ると苦しみがあるんですね
たとえ超能力であろうと
だからお釈迦様は ちょっと道が違うとということで 何も言えなかったし
本人にまた能力ないんですね
大体何か欲しがる場合は それは能力ないんですよ
だからありがたく見えちゃうんですね　ああなりたい こうなりたい　みんなやるでしょう
小さい時でも こういうふうになんとかなりたいとか　音楽家になりたくて必死に苦労すると
本当は才能ない だからありがたく大きく見えちゃう
才能ある人にとっては何のこともない
ごく普通なことで もう淡々と成功していきますよ
それも人間の心の悲しいところなんですよ
ないものは 隣の芝生が綺麗に見えるという 諺がありますね
だから もうそれは心の悲しいところですからね
だから彼に才能もないし お釈迦様も何もしなかった
彼が還俗して 他宗教に入ってお釈迦様を侮辱し始めたんです
ブッダっていうのはただの論理ばっかし
ただ論理でぺちゃぺちゃ喋ってるだけだと
口が上手だからと 何のこともないんだと 彼のところに
でも彼が言う通りにやると
やっぱり効き目がありますよと
その一言 入れるんですよ
もう彼がただの理屈ばっかり喋ってるんだけど
まあやってみると 結果がないとは言えませんと
なぜかというと この人も修行し
出家して真面目に修行してみたんですね
その分 すごくいい結果があるんです
だから自分が味わった結果だから
それは否定したくないんです
だから他人が あんた全く何もできなかった と聞いちゃうと
ちょっとプライドが傷つくし
ですが いえ そうでもない
頑張ってみたら それなりに結果がありましたよと
というところも言っちゃう
それでお釈迦様の反応は
あの愚か者が私を侮辱しようとして頑張ってるんだけど
結局 私を褒めているんだと
それぐらいの能力ないんだと
人を侮辱するんだったら はっきり侮辱してほしい
侮辱しようとして褒めたって意味がないしと言って
その場合でも やっぱりこの仏教というのは
必ず結果が出る 即効性あるというようなことなんですね
で それからこの 怒りに対抗してはいけないと
そういうのはもう火事に 火に例えていますよ
怒りが生まれたら 誰かのせいで怒ってしまえば
私がかえってその人に怒ると
そうすると自分が火だから
火に薪を 燃料をあげればあげるほど 火が燃えるんであって
消えるわけじゃないんですね
だから怒る人に怒るなよと
欲張ったりすると逆に欲張らないと
そういうふうな教えを教えてるんですね
自分を憎しむ人に対して
自分が憐れみをするんだと
物惜しみにはお布施しなさいと
この消す方法を教えているんですね
だから仏教では敵を倒せません
これ どれほど厳密に言っているかというと
恐ろしい犯罪者たちが来て
我々を捕まえて ノコギリで手足を切断するとします
生のまんまで 恐ろしい人々がもう何の悪いこともしていない自分をそうやって
足をノコギリで切断する
両手を切断すると その時でも
あなたは嫌なやつらだなという 嫌な気持ちさえを起こしちゃうと
それ私の道ではないと
それが私の道じゃないんだと
かすかにでも悪人に対して怒りがつくんだから
だからそれがこの理想というか
このいわゆるモデルになる例えなんですね
これはもうノコギリの例えという経典
有名な経典でね どれぐらい我々は敵に対して哀れみ持つべきかということ
それ以上ひどい目には誰も会いませんからね
で その道が間違っているという人々がいます
敵に対してどうすればいいかと
やっぱり悪人だから放っておけないと
倒すべきですよと それで悪が消えると勘違いする
例えば10人 悪い人がいる
10人殺しちゃえば それで悪が消えると思っちゃいます
それ消えません どんどん増える
だから敵を倒すべきじゃないんです
敵を哀れむんです 協力してあげて
味方にしてあげようとする
それができればやってみる
そうすると じゃあ仏教の人々っていうのは
悪い人々を野放し
野放しにするんでしょうかと
で 恐ろしい犯罪者やらテロたちやらね
野放しにするとどうなるかというと
どうせ狂ってるおかしい人々だから
どんどん被害が増えちゃいますよ
だから野放しにするのも知恵じゃないんです
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？戦うことも知恵じゃない
戦う一番悪い 野放しにすると
もうあれほど 戦うよりは危険ないかもしれませんけど
やっぱり危険はいくらかでも増えちゃいますね
じゃあどうすればいいかと
すごいいい言葉があります
見放す 見放したら終わり
何もできません それで自分の火で自分が燃えて終わっちゃうんです
もう一人の人に 火をつけることはできません
だから智慧が見放すことなんです
なぜかというと この世の中で我々は 互いに関係なくては生きていられません
もう世界的にも 指名手配されているその人も
一人ででは何一つもできませんよ
みんなの協力がないと 何一つもできません
それは事実です だったら見放しましょう
じゃなく そう見放す
それがこの世の中の人々にできないんですね
仏教はします 例えば この1年ぐらい前かな
タイで ちょっと出来事を起きたんですよ
あるお坊さんが この なんか
何て言いますか 衣の上で普通の在家の人の服を着て
ある女の人に行っていたんです ところに
で そういう女性のところに行っちゃうと
それで戒律は全部 無効で お坊さんではないんです
だから絶対禁止の世界
厳しいだからね 戒律が
それでその人を警察か軍隊か行って
情報入っちゃって 捕まったんです
捕まってテレビでも BBC でも放映したんです
その人 捕まってすごい体格の人でも
着てる服なんか軍隊の人とか全部ばらしちゃったんで
それで中 この衣なかったんだけど
下の衣とか着ているんですね
だからそれだったら 仏教に対しては大変な不名誉なことでしょうに
坊主っていうのはそんなもんかと
隠れて着替えて 女のところに行くもんかと
ふうなことは イスラム
タイでもカトリック教とかいるし
かなり仏教に対して いろんな対立しているんだけど
それは一つもできなかったんです
なぜかというと 仏教の世界はきれいにその人は見放す
お前のせいと ブッダのせいでもお坊さんたちのせいでもない
悪いのは君だと だから自分やったことの結果は自分で受けなさいよ
そういうことで 仏教の世界は何の問題もなく いまだに尊敬されています
それにかえて 今の現在の社会のことを考えちゃうと
このテロに攻撃するぞということは
イスラム人のある一人の人に攻撃することは
イスラム教に対する攻撃だと
故にイスラムの国々みんな 聖戦として聖戦ですね
まあ戦うべきですよというところで
ある頭のおかしい一人の人イコールイスラム教ですよ
だからラディンがイスラムですかね
だから屁理屈というと 見放しちゃえばいいのに
一人一人がどのように生きているかということは
どんな宗教にしても同じことでしょうに
あるカトリック教の人が悪いことをしたんだからといって
カトリック教が悪いんだよと言えないでしょうに
その人をもう見放しちゃえばいいでしょうに
見放すことは 残酷なことじゃないんですよ
だってカトリック キリスト教から見ても
人が罪を犯しちゃったらどうしようもないんだから
それは個人の責任なんです
だから個人が勘違いしてでも
精神的な問題があっても
何でもいいんですけど
何かしたんだからといって
この全体的な教えの責任にするのはよくないんですね
だからイスラム教の この本当にこのタリバンというのは
もう学者でもそうですね
コーランの　その人々に
このラディンイコールイスラムというのは間違っているよ とわからないんですね
なんでしょうかね それは
だから我々の世界 人間の世界では一人では生きていられません
だから仏教でこの悪人というかね
どうにもならん 社会に迷惑いうことを聞いてくれません
敵を味方に回そうとしたっても
話は聞かない   もう手に及ばない
だったら見放しましょうと
見放したら もうすぐその人は一人
自分が作った木で 自分で燃えて終わっちゃうんです
それは悪いことでも何でもないんですよ
悪を犯した人は どうしてもその苦を受けるんだから
その見放すということが
私はお釈迦様がおっしゃっている すごい智慧だと思います
我々には与える このすごい厳しい罰はそれなんです
いろいろサンガっていうのは社会で生活するでしょうし
そのいろいろ社会の サンガの社会のしきたり破ったらもう 厳しいんですよ
我々は社会戒律に対してはものすごい神経質か
お坊さんたちに会う時は
もう今日でも三人だったんです
いつでもどこで誰が座るかということに対しても
ものすごい緊張するんですね
それで長老が私に 前に座ってください
私はもうこれはもうダメということで
自分で座布団を持って別のところに行ったら
まあいいや それすぐわかりますから
じゃったらこちらだよと
そこでミャンマーのイントネーションで私にお経 経典あげられませんから
私はもう一人若いミャンマーのお坊さんがいて
じゃあ あなたこちら座って
私はこちら座りますと
二人であげてください と言っちゃうと順番 変わるんですね
座る順番が それで言ったら
この人はいいよと決めたんだけど
またすぐもう緊張して
もう長老を真ん中にして 両側座ったんです
そうすると また順番が崩れないんですね 座る順番が
どこに座っても 関係ないんだけど
やっぱりその小さいところでも 我々はすっごく気をつける
社会の戒律だから それで破ったらどうなるかというと
罰があります どんな罰かと見放される
サンガから　勝手にしろと
それで生きていられないんです
お釈迦様は在家の時
運転手さん　運転手っていうのはおかしいんですけどね
まあ人いたんですよ　随分仲が良くて 友人で
在家の時 どこへ行ってもその人と一緒に馬車を
その人は馬の管理して 連れて行くんですね
だからいつでも一緒だからね
随分お互いにまあ仲がいい
でお釈迦様出家して悟ってからは
ものすごいたくさんの人々が集まっているんですね
インドにいた すべての知識人たちがそちらに集まっていて
この人も 後から出家したんですけど
自分にとっては全然 立場がないんですね
一緒に座っていろいろ話すとかね
友達みたいに君どう？とかね
お釈迦様は何ひとつもしゃべれませんし
で ただ一人のお坊さんだから
それで本人がちょっと機嫌が悪くなっちゃったんです
お釈迦様は仲良くしてくれないんだから
それで みんなにいろんな嫌味をいう
今更あなた方は偉いバラモン人が出家して
お釈迦様のそばに座って話し合ったり
お釈迦様の命令を聞いたり いろいろしていても
私ですよ その方と一緒 昔から 子供頃から一緒にいたの
遊んだのは 私と一緒に遊んでいたんだよと
だから もうお坊さんの言うことを聞かない
なんで私は あなた方言うことを聞く必要ありますかと
ブッダっていうのは 私と一緒に
子供の頃 ボール遊びやら いろいろなことをした人でしょうと
でお釈迦様 これが良くないと わかっていたんだけど
やっぱり一緒に育てられた二人だから 何も言えなかったし
それで亡くなる前に 見放しなさいよと その人
一言 言って亡くなったんです
それも愛情で 慈しみで言うんですよ
チャンナを見放しなさいよと
それでお坊さんたちは　まあはい わかりましたということで
何のことなく お釈迦様の最後にすべてのことをして
葬式やら それから 第一次結集ということがあって
それもしたんですよ 何にもなかったように
それしてから もうお釈迦様のこういう言葉がありますからとサンガが集めて
これからチャンナ比丘をサンガからいわゆる
隔離すると 見放すということを決めたんです
決めて そのお坊さんのところに一人の代表者がいて
あなたにはこういう罰をお釈迦様決めたので
もう決めましたと 報告したんです
それで彼がそれはどういう罰ですか？これは見放すだけですと
あんたとしゃべりませんと 誰も
あんた勝手に喋ったっていいんだけど 我々喋りませんと
これから一人の比丘もあなたと喋れません
喋ったらそれも戒律違反です
それ聞いただけで 彼が失神して倒れちゃったんです
罰を聞いただけで 倒れちゃって
何のこと あとで気が付いちゃって
お釈迦様は亡くなる時でも
これぐらい私のことやっぱり考えていたんだと
自分がなんという生き方をしてきたんですかと
なんで強情で誰とも仲良くしないで生きてきたんでしょうかと言って
すぐもうしょうがない　お坊さんたちも喋ってくれないし
その罰を もう解除してくれませんし
だから必死になって一人で修行して悟ったんです
悟り開いたら自動的に解除
だから仏教の目的は悟ることだから
もう戒律はいらないということで
それでやっと解除してもらったんですね
ですから 仏教というのは いろんなどんな問題にも すごい即効的な答えを出してます
今のイスラムの方々でも ほとんど貧しいでしょうし 苦しいでしょうしね
だから ラディンはイスラムではありませんし
サウジアラビアのあの金持ちの王様は イスラム教がその人ではありませんし
みんな個人個人でしょうに
俺を殴ったんだから イスラム教を侮辱したんだよというのは とんでもない話でしょうに
もし私を人が殴ったならば
それはスマナサーラを殴ったんであって
仏教を侮辱したことではないんですね
ですから 仏教そのものを侮辱することはすごい罪であって
イスラム教を侮辱することというのはとんでもない
とんでもない良くないことであって
人が悪いことをすると 何だというのは 誰にでも権利があります
ですから この よく全部知ってるんだという こういう人は
私はこのパキスタンの大統領の 国民に向かって喋ったものは全部 聞いていて
それからブッシュさんがね
コングレス(congress: 連邦議会) で喋った話も全部聞いてみたんですけど
やっぱり頭が悪いなとかね
人間を幸福にする道がわかってないなとか
しょうがない 当たり前ですけどね
例えばパキスタンの大統領
あれほど苦労する必要ないでしょうに
個人が何かしたならばね
それは個人のことで 我々の偉大なイスラム教はそんなことではありません
一言で言えばそれだけのことでしょうに
アメリカはもう別に 法律国家だから
決してこの無差別に 法律に従わないで彼を裁くことはありませんと
彼が犯人であるならば ちゃんと証拠を調べて
裁判を起こすでしょうと
ですから 我々はもう彼が悪いことをするというならば
どうぞ調べてください というのは
我々の宗教を守ることだ というふうな立場で喋るべきところで
タリバンの人々もそういう態度を取るべきことであって その知恵がない
守ってあげるのは意味がないんです
だから それもやっぱりこの即効性の一つの例を出したのは
この現代 今はちょっとみんなに興味ある
みんなに心配してる問題ですからね
だからやっぱり我々は 悪人に対しては見放す
もう社会からもどちらから
例えば日本の社会でも みんななんで悪いことをしないかというと
この見放す現象がありますね
ちょっと やり過ぎるところまでありますけどね
だから みんなすごい気をつけて生活しています
日本で見放すというのは 犯人じゃないんです その家族なんです
息子が人殺しちゃうと
その家族親戚 みんなもう見放しちゃうんですね
それは仏教は認めません
恐ろしいと 息子が人殺したんだからといって
お母さんはどうするんですかね
かわいそうでしょうに
とにかくそれはそれで置いておいて
この見放す現象がね 日本にあるんだから
みんなかなり 他人に迷惑をかけないで
あまり悪いことをしないで よく気をつけているでしょうね
ですから それは決して恐ろしいことではありません
ですから 我々はやっぱりどうにもならない
どうしても育てることできない場合は
完全に見放しちゃうと
その一個の人が自分の自業自得で苦しんで終わるだけであって
他人には迷惑はない世界が生まれてきますね
ですから そこら辺も今の現代世界でみんな知ってるんだったら
世界が もっと幸せな世界になるだろうと思いますね
憎しんで憎しんでもう 報復行為やらね
それよりは関係ない人まででもね
もう六千人以上死んじゃって
まあそれで十分でしょう
その人々の死を無駄にしないで
それが世界平和につながるならばね
いいことなんですけど
そういうことで やっぱり私が最後に言いたいのは
やっぱりブッダの教え
より大勢の人々が聞いて理解してね
これは宗教ではないし
ものすごいジリジリした真理 事実でしょうしね
だからこの 自分のためにもなるし
すべての生命のためにもなる教えですから
これからよく勉強して 修行していただきたいということで 話を終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございます